die nachrichten des tages heute mit nie
kritisiert ihnen allen einen schönen
guten abend an diesem 19 januar und im
sport mit katja stresow schauen wir
unter anderem auf neue sorgen bei der
handball-nationalmannschaft leider ja
schon guten amt und hier ganz
übersichtlich für sie unsere themen
das rk ii meldet erstmals über 100.000
neuinfektionen an einem tag
gesundheitsminister lauterbach rechnet
mit dem höhepunkt der welle erst mitte
februar
sorge vor einer militärischen aggression
us-außenminister blinken stärkt der
ukraine im konflikt mit russland den
rücken
und drei weitere bewohner fälle im
deutschen em team jetzt sind insgesamt
zwölf handballer in quarantäne über
[Musik]
100.000 infektionen binnen 24 stunden in
deutschland noch nie haben sich bei uns
so viele menschen mit corona angesteckt
gleichzeitig sinkt die belegung auf den
intensivstationen dass die omikron
variante offenbar milder verläuft ist
für den gesundheitsminister kein grund
zur entwarnung er mahnt zur vorsicht
wird weiter für eine impfpflicht und
erwartet den höhepunkt der welle erst in
einem monat dazu christoph destor
l112
1323 neuansteckungen an einem tag eine
rekordzahl die man einordnen muss um das
derzeitige infektionsgeschehen zu
überschauen seit zwei wochen steigt der
wert rasant und mit ihm die sieben tage
incidents die jetzt bei 5 184,4 liegt
aber noch viel mehr hat sich seit herbst
verändert omikron bläst vor allem durch
die eng besiedelten ballungsgebiete
bremen etwa hat eine inzidenz von fast
1300 berlin frankfurt und münchen melden
um die 1000 dagegen liegen einzelne
ländliche hotspots von früher in sachsen
zum beispiel momentan unter 200 und
thüringen gesamt kommt auf 216 mit noch
fallender tendenz
interessante auch die altersverteilung
das virus grassiert vor allem unter
schülern bei den fünf bis 14 jährigen
ergibt sich eine inzidenz von
in richtung ältere wird sie immer
kleiner beträgt bei den über 80-jährigen
mit 122 fast genau zehn mal weniger was
wohl auch die heutige zahl der
todesfälle erklärt
239 menschen starben binnen tagesfrist
vor einer woche waren es 384
hospitalisierung intensiv fälle auch
dort sind die zahlen rückläufig aber all
das ist wohlgemerkt nur eine
momentaufnahme von omikron ich glaube
dass wir also den höhepunkt der welle
wahrscheinlich mitte februar erreichen
werden dann können die fahrzeuge auch
wieder sinken aber wir sind noch nicht
auf dem höhepunkt angekommen was droht
also zum beispiel für das öffentliche
leben ungefähr kann man das hochrechnen
wenn wir von so einer zahl 400.000
neuinfektionen pro tag ausgeben wie wir
das zum beispiel auch in frankreich
sehen dann kann man das grob abschätzen
was das bedeutet wenn jede person etwa
eine woche ausfällt dann hat man halt
mehrere millionen menschen die
gleichzeitig sozusagen ausfallen diese
busse und bahnen polizei feuerwehr und
krankenhäuser würden vielleicht auf
rumpf betrieb runterschalten müssen und
auch für die intensivstation ist es zu
früh für eine entwarnung
eine entwarnung im schwelenden ukraine
konflikt ist ganz und gar nicht in sicht
stattdessen werden forderungen nach
defensivwaffen für die ukraine lauter
gegenseitige drohungen nehmen zu die
russische seite weiß um unsere
entschlossenheit sagte kanzler scholz
heute beim weltwirtschaftsforum
us-außenminister blinken warnte beim
besuch in kiew vor der aufstockung
russischer truppen an der ukraine grenze
andreas huppert
ein ukrainischer militärposten an der
grenze zu russland irgendwo dort in der
ferne die russen mit mächtiger
streitmacht ihnen gegenüber die ukraine
mit veraltetem militär
amerikas außenminister blinken hat heute
bei seinem besuch in kiew noch einmal
bekräftigt die usa werden helfen
finanziell und militärisch
und wie verhält sich deutschland gibt es
gar waffenlieferungen bundeskanzler und
außenministerin sind da klar sprechen
mit einer stimme und sagen dass keine
legalen waffen geliefert werden lädt
alle waffen also todbringende waffen die
wir auch der koalitionspartner fdp nicht
an die ukraine liefern angesichts der
lage fordern die liberalen aber
weitergehende militärische unterstützung
nicht mit legalen waffen aber
möglicherweise eben mit cyber ausbildung
mit sanität und mit einem missions-
programm um die dortigen soldaten zu
trainieren september 2014 deutschland
liefert waffen an die kurden im kampf
gegen die terroristen in syrien auch
damals war dem eine lange politische
diskussion vorangegangen es ist eben so
das können wir nicht in abrede stellen
dass mit russland eine großmacht
involviert ist zu der sowohl deutschland
als auch die eu eine besondere beziehung
haben es gibt ein großes interesse in
berlin diesen konflikt friedlich zu
regeln und so setzt der bundeskanzler
weiter auf die diplomatie beim
virtuellen davos treffen des
weltwirtschaftsforums mahnte er die
territoriale unversehrtheit der ukraine
an rasch ist die russische seite weiß um
unsere entschlossenheit ich hoffe ist
auch der bus dass der nutzen von
kooperation deutlich höher ist als der
preis weitere konfrontation von tischen
und so bleiben die spannungen zwischen
der ukraine und russland weiterhin real
eine militärische eskalation nicht
ausgeschlossen
im ukraine konflikt oft frankreichs
präsident auf die wiederbelebung der
friedensgespräche zwischen russland der
ukraine deutschland und eben frankreich
makro will im jahr der französischen
ratspräsidentschaft
europas rolle stärken und sich
gleichzeitig für die wahlen im eigenen
land in stellung bringen über seine
europa pläne die er heute in straßburg
vorstellte gunnar krüger an europas rand
droht ein krieg in seinem zentrum tobt
der balkan emanuel makro in straßburg
zum start der ratspräsidentschaft sein
anspruch für die eu ist souveränität in
wirklichkeit hat sie in der ukraine kaum
gewicht bisher
novelle hier brauchen einen europäischen
vorschlag für eine neuordnung der
sicherheit und statt den müssen wir
zuerst mit unseren nato partnern teilen
und darüber dann mit russland verhandeln
makro fordert seit seiner ersten wahl
seit seiner rede an der universität zur
burn mehr europäische souveränität bei
den themen verteidigung und wirtschaft
bislang ohne erfolg auch in berlin jetzt
wirklich die möglichkeit die ambitionen
von marken seit april und die ambition
dieser neuen ampel regierung in berlin
zusammen zu bringen souveränität sein
schlagwort steht den koalitionsverträgen
von berlin bis den haag doch jeder
versteht anderes darunter wie bei max
zweiten punkt mehr schulden für mehr
investitionen mai konnte das nochmal
inland war da nicht immer ein partner
ich hoffe die niederländische regierung
zeigt nunmehr guten willen sowie die in
berlin ich hoffe es mit wilma kranken
ernten was er vor jahren hätte wenn er
partner findet heute warb er um das
vertrauen der abgeordneten und vom
stimmen seiner rede
großbritanniens premier johnson der hat
schon so manchen skandal an sich
abprallen lassen diesmal allerdings
könnte es eng werden für ihn abgeordnete
der eigenen partei wollen ihm offenbar
das misstrauen aussprechen auch die
bevölkerung ist laut umfragen
mehrheitlich für einen rücktritt ein
grund in downing street number ten dem
amtssitz des premiers wurden
gartenpartys gefeiert gartenpartys
während im land ein strenger corona
lockdown galt andreas stamm aus london
die frage die sich alle stellen schallt
ihm entgegen
ist es vorbei zeit zu gehen boris
johnson am mittag auf dem weg ins
unterhaus dort bin auch der
oppositionsführer wissen
muss sein premier der das parlament
belügt nicht zurücktreten es läuft eine
untersuchung und ich werde nicht weiter
spekulieren was dabei herauskommt
die interne untersuchung soll klären hat
der premier gewusst dass bei feiern in
seinem amts und wohnsitz coroner
restriktionen gebrochen wurden johnsons
erklärung er war einmal anwesend aber
niemand habe ihm gesagt es handle sich
um eine party
er verlangt dass wir glauben dass er das
nicht selbst erkannt hat während er
durch tabletts voller sandwiches und
leerer flaschen stiefelte ein damaliger
top berater erklärt dagegen ganz klar
johnson wusste bescheid ironie der
geschichte verschworen hat sich wohl ein
teil der 107 abgeordneten die erst durch
seinen erdrutschsieg bei den jüngsten
wahlen ins parlament kamen diese
brauchen 54 briefe von tory
parlamentariern die einen
misstrauensvotum auslösen und 20 seien
es schon viele warten wohl auf dem
untersuchungsbericht auch in den eigenen
reihen sind die messer gewetzt
ich habe den premier über wochen und
monate verteidigt oft gegen empörte
wähler du hast so lange hier gesessen
trotz guter taten in gottes namen
johnson will nicht kämpft erklärt dass
nun alle chor ohne einschränkungen
aufgehoben werden herzenswunsch vieler
konservativer sein vielleicht letzter
verzweifelter rettungsversuch eines pre
dies auf abruf
31 männer und acht frauen aus vietnam
hatten die hoffnung auf ein besseres
leben in europa aber auf ihrer schleuser
reise erstickten sie qualvoll im
laderaum eines lastwagens
jetzt hat ein gericht im belgischen
brügge eine gruppe menschenschmuggler
verurteilt chef der gruppe ein
vietnamese bekam 15 jahre haft 17
weitere helfer erhielten haftstrafen bis
zu zehn jahren im oktober 2009 10 war
der kühllaster mit den leichen der
vietnamesischen migranten im südosten
englands entdeckt worden
die staatsanwaltschaft berlin ermittelt
gegen den gesamten bundesvorstand der
grünen also auch gegen vizekanzler
habeck und außenministerin baerbock der
vorwurf verdacht der untreue die
mitglieder der parteispitze sollen sich
widerrechtlich selbst einen so genannten
corona bonus von jeweils 1500 euro
bewilligt haben darüber wurde bereits im
vergangenen jahr berichtet daraufhin
seien strafanzeigen eingegangen nach
angaben eines parteisprechers haben die
vorstandsmitglieder die umstrittenen
boni inzwischen zurückgezahlt
oft schweigen sie aus angst oder scham
die opfer sexualisierter gewalt eine
neue plattform gibt ihnen jetzt eine
stimme 100 berichte über
vertrauensbrüche hilflosigkeit und
ohnmacht hat die unabhängige kommission
zur aufarbeitung sexuellen
kindesmissbrauchs jetzt ins netz
gestellt bedrückende zeugnisse die aber
allen opfern mut machen sollen sich
ihrer geschichte zu stellen heike
slansky berichtet an die hundert mal ist
er als junge von seinem trainer
missbraucht worden berichtet boris
kaminski der täter gesellschaftlich
angesehen sogar freund der familie
zweifel kamen ihm erst viel später auf
das habe ich als 10 11 jähriger nicht
hinterfragt als es eben zu den ersten
missbrauchsvorfällen kam und hab dann
extrem lange gebraucht und das zu
verarbeiten um wirklich zu verstehen was
im detail passiert ist wie letztendlich
die ganzen zusammenhänge waren wie viele
mitwisser ist gab geschichten die zellen
so heißt das portal das opfern die boris
im netz gehör verschafft berichte die
gnadenlos und beklemmend sind für ganz
viele betroffene gibt es keinen weg zur
justiz war ihre geschichte verjährt ist
und deswegen ist das öffentlich machen
das sprechen das anerkennen auch eine
möglichkeit
gerechtigkeit zu transportieren
traumatische erlebnisse eine
gesellschaft die wegschaut die dhs
schätzt in jeder deutschen schulklasse
sitzen ein oder zwei betroffene kinder
glaube es ist wichtig dass wir die
gesellschaft sensibilisieren und
aufklären über dieses thema und deshalb
wird es auch eine große kampagne geben
mit dem familienministerium gemeinsam
mit dem unabhängigen beauftragten denn
die zahlen sind absolut erschreckend und
alarmieren 30 jahre lang quälten ihn die
erinnerungen an seinen lieblingssport
erst seit kurzem greift boris kaminski
wieder zum tennisschläger auch er will
aufklären und andere opfer bestärken sie
wissen lassen du bist nicht allein
eine kleine aber laute minderheit geht
gegen die korona maßnahmen auf die
straße immer wieder kommt es dabei zu
gewalttaten so auch bei demonstrationen
anfang januar im sächsischen bautzen
gegen zwei männer wurden beschleunigte
verfahren eingeleitet die sind möglich
wenn eine klare beweislage vorliegt
cornelia schiemenz über den
urteilsspruch
acht monate auf bewährung und eine
geldzahlung von 1000 euro an einen
polizeisportverein so das urteil heute
im landgericht bautzen
das gericht sah es als erwiesen an dass
der 21-jährige bei protesten gegen die
korona maßnahmen einen beamten umgerannt
sowie gegen das versammlungsgesetz
verstoßen hat es ist ja ein
pädagogischer grundsatz dass die strafe
nach möglichkeit auf dem fuß folgen
sollte und in diesem fall ist es
sicherlich auch eine überlegung dass
deutlich gemacht werden soll das
rechtsverstöße im zusammenhang mit
diesen corona protesten nicht folgenlos
bleiben die tat ereignete sich am 3
januar als die gewalt auf deutschen
straßen eskalierte als sich hunderte
menschen auf dem kornmarkt versammelten
und ihrer wut freien lauf ließen das
urteil heute erfolgte nach kurzem
prozess in einem schnellverfahren
protestforscher sind skeptisch ob diese
schnellverfahren eine abschreckende
wirkung haben werden
in bautzen wird wohl auch deshalb weiter
protestiert werden jeden montag denn
corona ist für viele nur der anlass
nicht der grund für den protest
als am freitag ein unterwasservulkan in
der südsee ausbrach löste er eine solche
druckwelle aus dass es sogar im fernen
berlin einen deutlichen ausschlag beim
luftdruck gab die eruption gewaltig
riesen aschewolken über dem hunger tonga
und es folgte eine tsunami-welle
mindestens drei menschen starben tonga
ist ein inselstaat im pazifik die
100.000 einwohner können jetzt wieder
telefonieren tage lang waren sie von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten die schäden
werden immer sichtbar war tobias häfner
hilfe kommt aus dem westen hilfe kommt
aus dem süden das ist die gute nachricht
die schlechte die schiffe aus australien
und neuseeland brauchen noch tage bis
tango
wir tun was wir können tonga ist ein
wichtiges mitglied unserer pazifischen
familie
neben medikamenten und lebensmitteln
wird am nötigsten trinkwasser gebraucht
erste vorräte sind an bord der
hilfsschiffe und der bedarf wird vorerst
hoch bleiben die tsunami welle und der
enorme ascheregen haben wasserreservoir
verschmutzt
ein schwerpunkt unserer hilfe liegt
darin entsalzungsanlagen zu liefern und
natürlicher wasserressourcen wieder
nutzbar zu machen
eben noch südseeparadies nun eine braun
graue asche wüste unter tropischer sonne
zwei zentimeter hoch ist die schicht auf
straßen häusern und pflanzen die
gewaltige vulkaneruptionen deren kraft
amerikanische experten auf etwa das 500
fache der atombombe von hiroshima
schätzen hat für den kleinen inselstaat
in wenigen stunden alles verändert
immerhin auch privat hilfsaktionen wie
hier in sydney kommen in gang es gibt
viele familien mit älteren oder
körperlich eingeschränkten menschen wir
wollen deren spezielle bedürfnisse
abdecken
ein lichtblick der flughafen ist nicht
schwer beschädigt reinigung von hand
dann können wohl schon ende der woche
hilfsflüge für tonga
duncan und
wir machen mit dem sport und katja
stresow weiter bitter die korona keule
hat wieder zugeschlagen im deutschen
handball sehr bitter sogar fast schon
zur nebensache wird der der souveräne
und etwas überraschende 30 23-erfolg
gestern abend bei der em gegen polen
aber in der tat drei weitere spieler der
deutschen handball-nationalmannschaft
wurden heute positiv auf das corona
virus getestet
zu beginn der nachmittagseinheit sicher
die nächste hiobsbotschaft durch djibril
mbengue
sebastian heilmann und christoph
steinert der neunfache torschütze gegen
polen die korona fälle 10 11 und 12
aktuell stehen alfred gislason somit für
das spiel morgen gegen europameister
spanien nur 13 gesunde akteure zur
verfügung ob es dabei bleibt fraglich
heute abend gibt es weitere pcr tests
deren ergebnisse dem kader noch einmal
reduzieren könnten ob es ein szenario
gibt das zu einem rückzug von dieser em
führen könnte dazu wollten sich die
verantwortlichen des dfb nicht äußern
bei den australian open in melbourne
steht deutschlands tennis profi nummer
eins alexander zverev in der dritten
runde mit 6 4 6 4 und 6 0 gewann er
gegen den australier john
millman ja heute selten weil alexander
zverev im hintergrund konsequent gegen
den australier ans netz läuft und dann
mit solchen wolle stopps glänzt firmen
verliert nicht nur den hals sondern auch
die ersten beiden sätze trotz heftigen
widerstands mit 6 4 6 4 im dritten satz
lässt der australier nur einmal seine
klasse aufblitzen bejubelt von seinen
fans wäre es dominiert mit 6 zu 0 in nur
28 minuten eher und philipp
kohlschreiber sind als letzte deutsche
noch im einzel wettbewerb
zum fußball genauer zum dfb pokal und
einem kiez club im freudentaumel denn
zweitliga spitzenreiter st pauli hat im
achtelfinale borussia dortmund mit 2 1
besiegt nach mäßiger gegenwehr durch
dortmunds abwehr traf etienne armee nido
zum 1 0 in der vierten minute kurz vor
der pause das eigentor von dortmunds
axel witsel 20 erling hollands treffer
durch handelfmeter half dann auch nichts
mehr der bvb ist raus st pauli weiter
mit einer million euro pokal prämie mehr
auf dem konto und noch dies dynamo
dresden trauert um seine klub ikone hans
jürgen genannt dixie dörner starb in der
letzten nacht nach langer schwerer
krankheit wegen seiner eleganten
spielweise war dörner auch als
beckenbauer des ostens bekannt der
ehemalige weltklasse verteidiger spielte
100 mal für die ddr auswahl wurde 1976
olympiasieger und war nach der wende
trainer bei werder bremen dixie dörner
wurde 70 jahre alt vielen dank für die
meldungen katja und wir sind jetzt beim
mittwochslotto und da lauten die
gewinnzahlen wie folgt 17 19 43 45 48 49
die superzahl 4 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf.de und auf der textseite
557 ja heute nacht schnee wind glätte
morgensonne mehr gibt es gleich von
katja horneffer um 21.45 innenministerin
nancy faeser im heute-journal interview
mit bettina schausten von uns war es das
danke fürs zuschauen entspannten abend
noch und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend jetzt kommt etwas bewegung
ins winterwetter und das liegt an der
kaltfront von tief wieder die uns heute
nachmittag bereits im norden und im
nordwesten erreichte mit regen und mit
gefrierenden nieselregen jetzt in der
nacht geht der regen besonders oberhalb
von 300 bis 500 meter mehr und mehr in
schnee über machen sie sich also auf
glätte gefasst auf straßen und gehwegen
und auch auf tief winterliche
straßenverhältnisse in den
mittelgebirgen dazu pfeift die an der
nordsee ein stürmischer wind aus
nordwestlichen richtungen und die
temperaturen sinken auf plus 3 bis minus
4 grad der schnee zieht dann morgen über
tag weiter südwärts und haben längst
schneit es noch hier am erzgebirgskamm
und auch am alpenrand dahinter
entwickeln sich schnee schnee regen und
graupelschauer und im östlichen
brandenburg kann sogar mal für ein
winter gewitter reichen entlang der elbe
bis hinauf richtung schleswig holstein
aber scheint die sonne zum teil
strahlend beim starken bis stürmischen
nordwestwind das ist dann der norwegen
füllen am alpenrand dagegen schneit es
am längsten und das bei temperaturen
zwischen minus ein und plus 6 grad und
winterlich geht es in den nächsten tagen
auch weiter guten abend